I think that what I love about New York City, there's a little bit of everything.
And every day when you get up and walk to school,...
...you might see something you've never seen before.
I love exploring.
Every street is different.
You're experiencing the real world with the college life.
What I love about New York is the diversity.
I like everything mixed together.
When I'm walking on the street I don't wanna see one of the few things.
I wanna see things that I don't even know what I'm seeing.
New Yorkers are busy not unfriendly.
They're really kind people and they know what's up.
What I find is that a lot of people that grew up...
...in those towns with triple-digit populations and everything...
...and then they come here.
They stay here.
I love this city and I'll always love this city...
...and it's going to be a part of me forever.